okay so this is adventure time pee luck
who the hell is this guy I'll tell you
who this guy is uh this is Jason laws
you know we were going through you've
seen me a lot of stuff you seen him in
uh what in the AI review Eve's a dragon
board he was one of the crazy family
members and in demo reel and pretty much
I was talking to about adventure time
cuz I was like I'm having trouble came
through these be logs I don't know what
to say and he's like well I've seen the
show I am obsessed with the show I love
it and if you ever need a help just
talking about it like I have all the
episodes you know memorizing stuff and
well practically I mean so so I'll go
ahead and help you out and that's a
second way he's gonna do because he
knows what's gonna happen everyone's
telling me like this show goes more
interesting places like actually like
really complex emotionally interesting
places and so someone who has not seen
it and someone that has can you know
share a little insight on this I just
think that's a better way to go so for
the next few episodes cuz they're so
short you're gonna see these clothes a
lot and this
sadly my slicked back hair style that
they have video getting confession but
yeah so we are gonna talk about this
episode here uh tree trunks ending
through sure through me first
I guess you were saying that like
whenever a happens like you won't can
see people's reactions to it right
there's certain episodes in certain
reveals or certain things that happen in
episodes where if you know it's coming
you just want to see people react
because like this one it's kind of like
did today poof and you're like what the
hell just happened there it scared the
out of me I was just like what and
even though it's like you see her in
some sort of jewel thing at the end sees
certain thing like okay well they'll
probably probably bring her back somehow
the six side of you is actually saying
should have shown it they shouldn't even
there were you bringing back just ever
blow up and never show anything else
until like whatever they have her back
or something so that really threw me for
a surprise on top of it again I love how
unpredictable the show is but on top of
it I love this character tree frogs I
like a zoo she showed up I just love how
like can she
is answer of loci and everything and she
really cracked me up and so far I think
I like this episode the most cuz it
seemed like for lack of her expression
it was sort of the most connected to
another character I just liked how much
they like treat rocks through this she
trunks is like their grandmother that
they love but at the same time it's a
bizarre love thing because if you look
at tree trunks how does she treat them
she talks to them about how her she has
sexual prowess and I want to give you a
kiss and it's just kind of this
uncomfortable we love you tree trunks
but you're kind of a bit creepy at the
same time so so it's okay you know that
that's something I was gonna enter so I
asked you to because in some of these
shows I mean it's not like sexual stuff
hasn't been shown in kids shows before
you know but it's strange actually
hearing the word sexy cuz they use it a
couple times in this show and it
especially just seeing like the cute
little elven say I'm gonna be sexy and
it was really weird it's one of the
things like do you know is that like
common now in kid shows is that sort
like a common word that nobody cares
about anymore I'm just an old fart yeah
I actually I think we're both old farts
no it's it's definitely something that's
become more common in kid shows and just
if you look at just average TV average
TV is now you can see like you can swear
a little bit on TV a little bit more
stuff is able to go further but when
they do this and they toss in sexual
it's you know kids are coming and the
adults are like oh wait I see that a
little bit different of a way I I'm not
saying it's necessarily bad because I
think like ever used to say like it's a
strange world where you can like in
Austin Powers IV you're saying you can
show a person drinking you just
can't say yeah and there is some
truth in that like you know you can show
whatever the x-men are all these
superheroes it's super you know like
very well-endowed characters like
showing off that they're very
well-endowed but if they say that
they're sexy it's like oh no no so at
the same time it was kind of a shock
hearing this especially it's such a
cutie show hearing it so it's it's nice
and unpredictable this whole she's
always unpredictable I can't predict
that thing that's gonna happen in the
show but at the same time it does sort
of throw me for a loop so I was
that's just something I haven't watched
enough kid shows is that more like a
common word or is that just it's that
something different this show does
no no it's become kind of pretty much
the norm at this point in time they
they're more loose with what they say by
comparison to when we were kids
without question okay so now is
something you were bringing up it
everyone's bringing up like even when I
was talking about should I keep these
feelings going they're like no please
just it gets really interesting it gets
really interesting emotionally complex
all this stuff oh is this an episode
that you would say sort of like does
this kind of stuff come back wait yeah I
start to notice the snail cuz you're
like you see the snail and I'm like yeah
there you see the snail yeah like what
is the deal with the snail and I guess
is there a deal with the snail I mean
you ought to tell me what it is but does
it actually come into play or well in
the beginning it started off as kind of
like an easter egg ah that there it
actually throughout the whole show each
episode has a bunch of little Easter
eggs hidden here and there but that's
like the consistent when the snail
appears in every episode in one form or
another sometimes for split second
sometimes for a good few second does he
ever like get a full episode at all
actually he becomes a very very very
important character see I'm like really
fascinated by this now cuz everyone's
saying like no this Cup like I guess all
these things come into play later just
without necessarily saying what or how
are there other things in this episode
that's like yes this is gonna come into
play later it's gonna be a big thing oh
yeah almost every episode it doesn't
matter
like I don't know if they were planning
like well well well well in advance or
if they kind of went back to the
episodes and were like you know what we
can use what was said here and we'll
place what is actually going on here and
connect it back to episode 1 everything
kind of has a connection to something
else characters will come back up later
on almost no one is forgotten about real
even if like a very minor character
comes up and then you don't see him for
like a bunch of episodes
they'll come they will eventually come
back into play sometimes as a minor role
or sometimes as an actual major player
in an episode that's right
so fast NICUs I would not predict that
of this show that's why I'm really fast
me and now we keep watching because so
many people have been saying this like
that it does really pick up or that it
picks up at least in the phrase I keep
using is emotional complexity but that's
a word everyone else keeps using so you
know I figure that's a good way to say
it
the only other thing I'll ask because
you brought it up in this episode is the
well is it you said something very
important is gonna be said here and the
dog says that Finn is 12 he said now you
know his age was it wasn't something I
was saying like yeah what is his age I
wasn't asking that but again does that
really play a part somewhere is that
something important to remember well yes
you know I mean watching your past V
logs and everything you were saying you
know you don't know anything about these
characters they're kind of just tossed
in your face okay now I know it's H
that's the thing instead of it being
like an episode where like first episode
you learn about everything the show is a
slow reveal of everything and most of it
said pretty much in passing you learn a
lot of the stuff just because it's
normal chitchat or between them like oh
don't worry about it he's 12 he can
handle it instead of it being like he's
12 years old
you know they handle it very much like
natural conversation whoa natural in
this show yeah show can be and the age
is important because and it's not really
giving anything away by saying this it's
he grows with the show so I like if a
year goes by he'll turn 13 and deaths
his birthday I actually celebrated and
he ages as the show goes along okay so
it's not like shows I do that but
actually especially animated shows cuz
you never see that yeah so I like I like
a show I can actually do it so that's
kind of cool and well that's a great way
to have the voice actor as he gets older
because it isn't it here is it oh okay
yeah as he gets older I mean he's
obviously the voices got changed that's
a good way to incorporate that in there
so cool yeah already I have a lot more
to talk about
Sonia you're gonna be a great help so
the next like five or six and each will
pricey like the exact same setup here or
maybe maybe some other people will be
another I don't know it is families over
there like I don't know just get I'm
sure they can say great stuff too so
maybe I'll just be two of us maybe be
more I don't know but you'll see this
set up a decent sex enclosed right the
next five or say you know or is it like
BMO go on maybe this was a bad idea by